la facture d'électricité des français va
forcément monter que désormais c'est
financés par les taxes qu'ils reportent
sur le carburant là les fameuses taxes
d'ailleurs qui ont provoqué la colère
des de gilet jaune en fait isolé pour
faire de l'écologie est tombé assez
difficile d'expliquer aux gens que on
laboure les fonds marins ont détruit un
écosystème humain économique et tout ça
pour le bien de la planète
[Musique]
marine le pen promet de combattre la
barbarie et appelle les français à se
réveiller
la présidente du rassemblement national
a prononcé son discours de rentrée
politique
aujourd'hui à fréjus dans le var elle
s'en est pris au ministre de la justice
eric dupond-moretti qualifié de taubira
empire
la france ne lèvera pas la garde au mali
déclarations de jean yves le drian
aujourd'hui après la mort de deux
militaires français de la force barkan
paris qui tente de rassurer ses
partenaires alors que des concertations
nationales son temps
le pays pour trouver une transition
politique les députés de la france
insoumise réclame un débat à l'assemblée
nationale sur les objectifs de
l'engagement français
le dossier turc priorités du prochain
conseil européen prévue fin septembre
selon le chef du quai d'orsay des
sanctions contre ankara serait à l'étude
la france accuse la turquie de mener une
politique expansionniste en méditerranée
orientale au coeur des tensions entre
paris et ankara
le dossier libyen les questions
migratoires et de sécurité et les
réserves de gaz
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france à la une
de l'actualité ce dimanche la rentrée
politique de marine le pen aujourd'hui
dans le var la présidente du
rassemblement national en a profité pour
dévoiler son slogan de campagne
français réveillez vous la situation est
grave sur le plan sécuritaire et
économique at elle dit en substance une
université d'été aux allures de pré
campagne pour la candidate à la
présidentielle qui a parlé de barbarie
nationale rémunéré ni en droit de se
demander ce qu'est devenu notre pays
vers quel abîme roule-t-il lorsque dans
le même temps tout est fait pour
neutraliser l'action des forces de
l'ordre les diffamer et les fragiliser
bref c'est une véritable barbarie qui
s'installe avec la barbarie on ne
négocie pas on la combat pour un
décryptage du discours de marine le pen
à présent avec arnaud benedetti
rédacteur en chef de la revue politique
et parlementaire
moi j'étais un discours qui visait
finalement à la faveur d'une actualité
qui la sert à réactiver les fondamentaux
du rassemblement national sur
essentiellement l'enjeu régalien et donc
sur la question sécuritaire
il est clair qu'aujourd'hui au delà de
la querelle des chiffres qui d'ailleurs
qu'elle montre ces deux dernières années
une hausse d'un certain nombre d'actes
délictueux
il est clair qu'il existe aujourd'hui
dans la société française dans de larges
segments de la société française à
sentiment d'insécurité qui s'est
installée et donc la marine le pen voit
dix ont remonté à l'agenda politique
l'un des thèmes préférentiel si je puis
dire du rassemblement national et même
du front national 2 cuill ça les sens et
on vient de l'apprendre un homme a été
poignardé ce soir gare du nord à paris
l'agresseur est en fuite l'attak a eu
lieu vers 17 heures la victime atteinte
à la gorge seraient dans un état grave
son pronostic vital est engagé selon les
pompiers
l'homme attaqué en fait une trentaine
d'années
et il attendait son train assis sur un
banc la sécurité décidément au centre
des débats politiques le ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin a promis
aujourd'hui que les chiffres sur la
sécurité serait publié désormais tous
les mois
il promet de les publier dans le détail
les résultats en matière de lutte contre
les stupéfiants
les chiffres des violences conjugales
les heures des patrouilles pédestres sur
la voie publique des gendarmes ou des
policiers
le nombre de dérives sectaires signaler
également entre autres un point presse
mensuel qui devrait se tenir à partir du
mois d'octobre au ministère de
l'intérieur le ministère de la justice
et plusieurs acteurs du monde judiciaire
français ciblés par une cyber attaque le
parquet de paris ouvre une enquête
préliminaire des magistrats des avocats
parisiens chargés de dossiers sensibles
ainsi que le procureur de paris rémy
heitz figurerait parmi les personnalités
visées par cette attaque
l' enquête a été confiée à la dgs si la
direction générale de la sécurité
intérieure un point sur la progression
de l'épidémie en france à présent avec
ces nouveaux chiffres publiés ce soir
sept mille nouveaux cas de covin 19
détecter ces dernières 24 heures c'est
un chiffre un peu en retrait par rapport
aux deux derniers jours
c'est près de 25 mille nouveaux cas en 3
jours 58 nouveaux foyers de
contamination détecté sur un total de
528 toujours en cours d'investigation
dont 214 dans les ehpad
à noter que trois décès supplémentaires
ont été enregistrés dans les hôpitaux
le rôle de la france au mali re fait
débat après la mort de deux soldats
français tués hier en opération pour le
ministre des affaires étrangères ces
décès ne remettent pas en question
l'engagement de la france au sahel
au total 45 militaires français sont
morts dans les opérations servat les
barkhanes lancé il ya sept ans mais pas
question pour autant de baisser la garde
a affirmé aujourd'hui jean yves le drian
écouter
il n'est pas question de lever la garde
nous sommes dans une phase au mali où
nous avons dessiné une stratégie de
renforcement de l'action qui commence à
donner ses effets il ya eu au cours de
ce semestre les reconquête de
territoires en particulier dans la
région des trois frontières elle c'est à
dire dans la zone entre le niger le
burkina faso et le mali est des
territoires sont revenus à la vie civile
des villageois sont retournés chez eux à
la présence de l'état revient les
députés de la france en soumise aux ont
réclamé aujourd'hui la tenue d'un débat
à l'assemblée sur les objectifs concrets
de l'engagement français au mali ainsi
que sur les conditions pour repartir
un débat qui n'a jamais eu lieu
jusqu'ici précise adrien catena ce
député elle est fille du nord
écoutez ça fait sept ans que la france
est engagée sur place sans que jamais
nos objectifs et été débattue
actuellement les maliens sont en train
de procéder à une révolution citoyenne
les militaires eux mêmes qui sont
engagés depuis sept ans là-bas disent
que la solution mali n'est pas une
solution militaire c'est une solution
politique
la situation sécuritaire dans le sahel
analyser à présent par dominique
trinquant expert des questions
militaires et ancien chef de la mission
militaire française à l'onu il n'est pas
tout de neutraliser les djihadistes il
faut encore que les états reprennent
place dans ces zones
et c'est là qu'est la difficulté et
c'est là que les liens avec ce qui se
passe au mali avec le coude et
actuellement que les forces françaises
et les forces du g5 voir la minus ma
établissent la sécurité dans ces zones
c'est une bonne chose mais derrière il
faut que les états reviennent
et lorsqu'on a un état instable
naturellement il ne revient pas comme ça
d'ailleurs dans la région de tessa vite
où a eu lieu l'incident
nous ne sommes pas loin de kidal et
kidal c'est la zone dans laquelle
l'armée malienne n'était pas revenu elle
est revenue aujourd'hui mais de façon un
peu symbolique et il faut absolument que
toutes les composantes des états
reviennent pour prendre la place de ces
mouvements djihadistes et montrer que
l'état de droit apporte la paix et la
sécurité aux populations au lieu dédié à
10 qui apporte l'insécurité le mali qui
a ouvert hier des concertations
nationales en vue d'une transition
politique des pourparlers qui doivent
durer une semaine
et en théorie les militaires qui ont
pris le pouvoir doivent le rendre aux
civils à l'issue de ces concertations
dans un communiqué emmanuel macron a
appelé à la mise en place sans délai
d'une transition politique civil pour
permettre de lutter efficacement contre
les terroristes
fin de citation les officiers maliens
eux ont assuré qu'ils n'allaient pas
traîner les noms il faudra les payer
mais sûrement
cet ancêtre images du comité national de
salut public après jc atim organisé cet
atelier de validation des thèmes
différents et ses attraits
cet incident est validée par les
participants et des références et la
rive à vue d'assurer une coopération
omis d de ce rendez-vous historique du
comité et pc le président déchu lui a
quitté bamako hier soir pour se rendre
aux émirats arabes unis ibrahim boubacar
keita aurait été victime d'un avc
l'ancien chef de l'état de 75 ans avait
été hospitalisé dans une clinique de la
capitale malienne
les militaires disent avoir accepté ce
transfert vers abu dhabi pour raisons
humanitaires mais sous conditions
puisque la cedeao se serait engagé à
faire revenir l'ancien président au
besoin sur demande de la justice
malienne
la rencontre entre le chef de l'état
français ivoirien avant-hier à l'elysée
a suscité la polémique dans les rangs de
l'opposition et cela alors qu'une
élection présidentielle ça va se tenir
le 31 octobre prochain
en cause le troisième la troisième
candidature d'alassane ouattara parmi
les candidats de l'opposition l'ancien
président laurent gbagbo dont charles
blé goudé proche
l'ancien chef des jeunes patriotes
ivoiriens à appeler à un report du
scrutin le 31 octobre prochain
voyez ce qu'en dit dini n'y a qu'au
coulibaly les vice présidents du parti
la nouvelle côte d'ivoire
nous sommes les premiers à dire que les
solutions de l'afrique notamment les
solutions de la côte d'ivoire doivent
aînés des ivoiriens eux mêmes mais vous
constatons tout simplement que je veux
dire avec tout le monde avec vous même
vous constatez que monsieur ouattara est
venu au pouvoir comment il a été
installé à la tête du pays
sans préjuger bien entendu des résultats
de l'élection de m
il a été installé grâce à la france et
la france constitue quand même un
partenaire de choix de la côte d'ivoire
et d'autres nous disons que nous pouvons
pas vivre en vase clos et c'est à partir
de ce moment que nous demandons
justement à la communauté internationale
et pas seulement la france d'ailleurs de
regarder ce qui se passe de réal et de
près ce qui se passe dans notre pays et
donc de tenir compte de cette réalité et
en fonction de cela
mettre la pression sur monsieur ouattara
qui s'est toujours présenté comme étant
quelqu'un qui qui est adoubé par la
communauté internationale qui a beaucoup
de relations et dont nous dépendons
justement à ces relations
aujourd'hui de prendre leurs
responsabilités et diamé sumatra qu'il
est temps qu'il parte et tu nous laisses
justement organiser des élections
transparentes claires pour que tous ceux
qui doivent être candidat plus être
candidat l'union européenne devrait
étudier des sanctions contre la turquie
lors du prochain conseil européen à la
fin du mois c'est ce qu'a annoncé jean
yves le drian alors que les tensions en
méditerranée orientale sont toujours
vives
la turquie qui reprend aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs de nouveaux exercices
militaires
une région riche en hydrocarbures source
de discorde également entre athènes et
ankara qui a brandi des menaces et la
medjahed explications
la série d'exercices militaires turcs et
baptisé tempête méditerranéenne les
exercices doivent se dérouler jusqu'à
jeudi prochain soit cinq jours de
manoeuvres militaires au large des côtes
chypriotes
des unités de l'armée installés dans la
partie turque de chypre non reconnue par
la communauté internationale doivent
aussi participer à cette opération aux
côtés des soldats d'ankara
une nouvelle démonstration de force en
pleine crise entre la grèce et la
turquie sur l'exploitation du gaz
naturel en méditerranée orientale
ce samedi le président turc a affirmé
que son pays était prêt et un partage
des ressources dans la zone mais pour
ankara le blocage vient de la partie
adverse
comprenez la grèce notre parole et
sincère le problème est que ceux qui
sont face à nous négligent nos droits et
se croient supérieurs ils vont
comprendre que ce n'est pas le cas ils
vont comprendre que la turquie a le
pouvoir politique économique et
militaire de déchirer les cartes et les
documents 1 morrow qui lui sont imposées
soit ils comprennent langage
diplomatique soit yvon quelque chose de
douloureux sur le terrain entre ces
menaces à peine voilées et les exercices
militaires turcs la désescalade en
méditerranée orientale s'éloigne un peu
plus
depuis le 10 août dernier ankara a
déployé un bateau de prospection
d'hydrocarbures au large de l'île
grecque de kastellorizo et à deux
kilomètres des côtes turques
la turquie qui mène également des
recherches dans les eaux territoriales
de chypre pour athènes et nicosie c'est
un viol de leur souveraineté
le premier ministre grec demande
d'ailleurs à la turquie d'arrêter ses
opérations avant toute discussion
il y à de nombreux commentaires exagérés
du président turc recep tayyip erdogan
juneau retient qu'un celui qui part
d'une volonté de dialogue et à cela je
réponds par six mots clairs les
provocations s'arrête le dialogue
commence ce vendredi le président
chypriote a dit de son côté son
inquiétude face à ce contexte très
volatil
pour lui ce conflit est clairement dû à
l'agressivité d'ankara la turquie agi de
manière provocatrice à chypre dans toute
la région en fête
poutine de stabilité mettant en péril la
stabilité et la sécurité de la région
la poursuite des opérations de forage
illégale de la turquie dans la zone
économique exclusive de chypre a conduit
à une militarisation à tence de notre
région
le président chypriote qui appelle
toutefois grec et turc à se mettre
autour d'une même table pour sortir de
ce conflit qui dure maintenant depuis
près d'un mois
l'otan dont la turquie et la grèce sont
membres annoncé cette semaine que les
dirigeants de ces deux pays avaient
accepté d'engager des pourparlers
une information ensuite démentie par
athènes en réaction la turquie avait
accusé la grèce de refuser purement et
simplement tout dialogue et voyez à
présent l'analyse de gérard vespière
fondateur du site le monde décrypté la
france a déjà pris des positions en
envoyant à quelques bateaux
supplémentaires en envoyant quelques
rafales
maintenant il s'agit on a des limites et
donc notre position et notre ligne à je
pense qu'il n'y aura pas de mouvement
nouveau sauf vraiment des dispositions
turc que l'on n'envisage pas
actuellement mais je ne crois pas que
les turcs eux or aux hommes verront
prendrons des décisions à pour une
escalade militaire
il en est pas question cela propre terre
d'or 1
la solution de ce cette tension n'y a
pas de conflit il ya une tension
donc l'objectif est de voir le maximum
de cartes dans le jeu turc et c'est ce
que les turcs essaye de faire
actuellement
donc en rose on ira parle vers d'autres
affrontements
au royaume uni attaque au couteau
aujourd'hui dans la ville de birmingham
la nuit dernière plusieurs personnes ont
été poignardées il y à un mort et deux
blessés graves
un suspect est toujours activement
recherché a annoncé la police qui ne
parle pas de la piste terroriste
nous traitons ces quatre incidents comme
une série liés nous recherchons un
suspect et des enquêtes sont en cours
pour identifier et retrouver ce suspecte
il n'y a absolument aucune suggestion
que cela soit lié au terrorisme ceci est
traitée comme une homicide sur lequel
enquête la police des midlands de
l'ouest
il semble bien qu'il s'agisse d'une
attaque aléatoire car nous n'avons pas
trouvé de lien entre les victimes
en ce qui concerne leur nature ou leur
lieu de socialisation et voyez à présent
le témoignage de ce gérant d'un
restaurant de birmingham
un homme noir et lé vers elle elle a
crié j'ai été poignardé quelque chose
comme ça elle a crié fort
elle a regardé autour et il continue
elle l'a poignardée il faisait juste
comme ça ils ne se battaient pas avec
elle ne l'a frappée pas en quoi que ce
soit avec une lame il faisait juste
comme ça
cette fois j'ai vu ça très très
clairement l'actualité internationale en
bref et en images
à présent plusieurs villes israéliennes
vont être confiné à partir de demain à
cause du rebond de l'épidémie dans le
pays les déplaçant dans 30 localités
seront limités les commerces non
essentiels seront fermés le pays qui a
dépassé le cap du millier de morts ce
week end
considéré au mois de mars comme un
exemple en tout cas dans la lutte anti
virus israël et depuis deux semaines le
cinquième pays au monde en termes de cas
d'infections par habitant devant le
brésil et les états unis
la tunisie frappé aujourd'hui par une
attaque terroriste à un gendarme a été
tué et son équipier blessé lors d'une
attaque au couteau à sousse dans l'est
du pays
les trois assaillants ont été abattus
par les forces de sécurité après des
échanges de tirs
la ville de sousse avec déjà été visé
par une attaque jihadiste meurtrière
c'était en 2015 en biélorussie à minsk
plus de 120 personnes arrêtées au cours
de ce cinquième dimanche deux
manifestations ils étaient des dizaines
de milliers vous voyez à s'être
rassemblés dans la capitale biélorusse
les protestataires qui manifestent
contre la réélection le 9 août dernier
alexandre loukachenko les forces de
l'ordre sont descendus en nombre dans
les rues la réfugiée en lituanie
sveltlana chicanos sky à la rivale
politique de l'actuel président s'est
exprimé sur les réseaux sociaux et elle
dit que seule une élection transparente
et équitable pour assortir la
biélorussie de la crise dans de
citations à la une cette semaine une
affaire qui empoisonne les relations
entre la russie et l'union européenne la
sphère alexeï navalni l'allemagne qui a
menacé la russie de sanctions si elles
ne fournissait pas de réponse dans les
prochains jours sur les causes de
l'empoisonnement présumé de l'opposant
russe avertissement lancé ce matin via
le quotidien allemand bild par le chef
de la diplomatie allemande
ce dernier évoque les risques d'impact
de la sphère qui pourrait être avoir des
impacts doucement sur le projet de
gazoduc north stream 2 qui lie les deux
pays une position 1 qui a été relayé par
son homologue britannique écouter fixer
des ultimatums n'aide personne
mais si dans les prochains jours la
partie russe ne contribue pas à
clarifier ce qui s'est passé alors nous
allons devoir discuter d'une réponse
avec nos partenaires
j'espère en tout cas que les russes ne
nous contraindront pas à changer notre
position sur north stream
il est très difficile quand à la
question d'attribuer l'empoisonnement de
monsieur navalni de penser à une autre
explication plausible que celle d'une
émanation de l'état russe
et justement côté russe dimitri peskov
le porte parole du kremlin répète que
les médecins russes qui ont traité
alexeï navalni dans les heures qui ont
suivi son malaise n'avait pas pu et m
un empoisonnement d'autres pistes
médicales sont à l'étude selon lui la
diplomatie russe qui dément toujours
toute implication et appelle berlin à
fournir des preuves
écoutez ici berlin a besoin d'une
réponse rapide
c'est surtout le côté allemand qui doit
agir promptement je voudrais souligner
que nous avons par l'intermédiaire du
service policier est proposé et même
envoyer les documents officiels et on a
parlé de la collaboration en mettant
l'accent sur le fait que l'interaction
doit être rapide et est encore les
médecins russes ont tout récemment
publié une lettre ouverte alors que
légalement il s'agit d'un document
officiel adressé au chef de
l'association médicale de l'allemagne
l'ambassadeur de russie s'est rendu au
ministère allemand des affaires
étrangères et a posé la question de
savoir s'il y avait des preuves
concrètes que le côté russe pourrait
obtenir pour les examiner et qui sont
indispensables pour l'anc est rien ne
lui a été transmise à ce jour nous avons
toujours le même problème
alors est ce qui concerne la promptitude
l'enquète les faits et la découverte de
la vérité
ainsi que d'autres exigences il faut que
berlin les adresses à soi même au liban
rencontre entre les dirigeants du
hezbollah et du hamas le mouvement
islamiste palestinien et c'est une
première depuis 30 ans hassan nasrallah
et ismaël haniyéh ont évoqué le site
les développements politiques et
militaires dans la région ainsi que les
projets arabes de normalisation avec
israël est un peu plus tôt cette semaine
sept
emmanuel macron qui s'est rendu au liban
retour sur cette visite du président
français avec hélène masquelier il avait
promis de revenir parole tenue
visite à la grande diva libanaise
fairouz plantation d'un cèdre dans une
forêt de byblos les symboles sont bien
présents mais emmanuel macron marche sur
un fil
l'objectif de cette deuxième visite
faire émerger un gouvernement de mission
comme il le qualifie en associant la
carotte et le bâton
macron laisse une dernière chance au
système libanais 6
rendez vous de fin octobre ce sur quoi
vos dirigeants se sont engagés n'est pas
au rendez vous nous devons en tirer les
conséquences alors qu'est ce que ça veut
dire ça veut dire soit rien n'a été fait
à ce moment là c'est clair je devrais
dire à la communauté internationale nous
ne pouvons pas être au rendez-vous de
l'aide au liban mais je devrai aussi
vous expliquer expliquer aux libanaises
et aux libanais nous étions prêts à vous
aider vos dirigeants en ont décidé
autrement
rencontre avec saad hariri avec le
hezbollah
le président michel aoun emmanuel macron
veut jouer la carte du compromis
le président français a également a
doublé le premier ministre désigné la
veille de son arrivée mustapha adib une
prise de position critiquée par certains
qui voient dans cette nomination un
changement de décor politique en trompe
l'oeil
nous disons à macron que nous sommes
contre le premier ministre désigné et
nous savons que matheron a choisi ce nom
est cette chose est inacceptable nous
sommes venus pacifiquement ici
transmettre le message à macron il veut
nous aider en tant que peuple libanais
par conséquent nous voulons lui faire
comprendre que la récente nomination du
nouveau premier ministre est à l'exact
opposé de ce qu'il dit s'il veut
réaliser nos exigences en tant que
peuple il doit réaliser nos exigences
à l'échelle de l'état démarche
postcoloniale voir ingérence pour
certains un pari libanais risqué pour le
chef de l'état qui ne souhaite pas en
rester là
une nouvelle conférence des
d'international est prévu en octobre et
une autre visite est déjà programmée
pour décembre le président français en
avait fait la promesse au peuple du pays
du cèdre
je ne vous lâcherai pas
et voyez ce que pensent de cette visite
du président français simon abi ramia
député du courant patriotique libre
face à l'impuissance des dirigeants
libanais de provoquer ces réformes et
pour répondre aux attentes de la
population libanaise et vu les relations
historiques qui lient le liban à la
france vous savez que libre était sous
mandat français
il ya des liens spécifiques entre les
deux pays et je crois que la visite du
président macron le 6 août au liban a
créé un espoir et une dynamique
politique
si c'est avéré à travers la nomination
rapide de nouveau premier ministre
je crois que la france qui a de très
bonnes relations avec toutes les
composantes politiques libanaises peut
jouer un rôle positif en ce sens c'est à
dire pas pousser vers des réformes
politiques tant attendu par la
population aux libanaises je crois qu'il
faut commencer à débattre entre nous
pour trouver un nouveau système
politique qui peut petit peu passé le
liban d'un état complètement
confessionnelles communautaire un état
un peu plus laïque et je crois que c'est
une revendication de l'art de la rue
libanaise
aux etats unis le mouvement black like
the matters est mobilisé pour la
centième journée en mai pour la centième
journée en mémoire à georges floyd
décédée sous le genou d'un policier
blanc mort il ya cent jours exactement
et les tensions entre manifestants et
forces de l'ordre sont toujours vives
retour sur une semaine d'affrontements
avec cécilia chaud sous la bannière du
slogan blake lively matters les
manifestants appellent à désarmer et
démanteler la police lui retirer ses
financements à washington comme à
rochester c'est la diffusion cette
semaine deux nouvelles vidéos d'homme
noir tué par des policiers blancs qui a
jeté de l'huile sur le feu à washington
le 2 septembre d'hillion qu'est 18 ans
décède d'une balle dans la poitrine en
fuyant les forces de l'ordre au
lendemain de la mort du jeune homme la
police diffuse elle même la séquence de
l'intervention pour montrer qu'il
portait une arme mais les images de
mauvaise qualité ne convainquent pas les
militants antiracistes
un rochester c'est la vidéo de la mort
de daimiel poudre diffusé mercredi qui a
fait monter la tension
le 23 mars dernier ce quadragénaire
atteints de troubles psychiatriques est
mort asphyxié par des policiers lors de
son interpellation
cet agent a été suspendue ce jeudi pas
de quoi calmer la colère des
protestataires est dispersée à coups de
gaz au poivre à times square où les
affrontements redouble de violence cet
incident une voiture non identifiés pour
leur fonce dans la foule
trois blessés à déplorer l'amérique
plonger dans la guerre civile
c'est l'opinion de soutien darron
danielson rassembler cette semaine à
portland mais aussi à vancouver mort la
semaine dernière ce membre d'un
groupuscule nationaliste aurait été
abattu par un homme blanc se réclamant
de la mouvance anti fasciste
ce dernier lui même tué par la police
cinq jours plus tard
[Musique]
signe d'un durcissement des tensions
l'explosion des ventes d'armes
d'après le fbi de janvier à juillet 2020
elles ont augmenté de plus de 70% par
rapport à la même période l'an dernier
et c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité sur notre antenne
on se retrouve dans 30 minutes rester
avec nous
[Musique]
nous allons évoquer ici des sujets
stratégiques pour notre pays et sur ces
dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous une
interprétation la croissance des pays
émergents
la stagnation des pays occidentaux et le
ralentissement de ceux en développement
ont rendu la compétition économique
internationale
brut 1 soyons clairs dans la guerre
économique
tous les pouces